Transcription: Diana Simões
Relecteur: eric vautier
Et si l’autre avait raison,
même quand je pense qu’il a tort ?
Ça ne vous est jamais arrivé
d’être convaincu d’un point de vue,
et, qu’à force de discussion,
vous finissiez par changer d’avis ?
Tout simplement parce que
votre première idée ne fait plus sens.
Moi, ça m’arrive très souvent,
et je suis très heureuse de vous dire,
qu’aujourd’hui, je le vis bien.
Pourquoi je vous dis ça ?
Parce que ça n’a pas toujours été le cas.
Pendant mes 30 premières années,
j’avais l’impression de devoir me battre
pour faire valoir mon point de vue.
J’avais l’impression aussi, dans un autre
cas, de céder au point de vue de l’autre,
avec cette sensation, vous savez, un peu
amère, d’avoir comme perdu la bataille.
Mais dans aucun des cas,
je n’étais à l’aise.
Ce que je vous propose là maintenant,
c’est d’enlever ce marteau du juge,
de retirer cette analyse
qui se demande avec la tête :
« Qu’est-ce qui est bien ? mal ?
Qui a tort ? Qui a raison ?
Qui est le meilleur ? »
Je vais déposer ce marteau juste à côté.
Ôter cette posture de juge,
en faveur d’une posture d’accueil,
d’accueil de ce qui est :
de vous, de moi,
des êtres humains.
D’être dans notre similarité,
dans notre équivalence.
Voilà, de vous parler de cœur à cœur.
Ceci étant posé,
je vais vous présenter comment faire,
lorsqu’une personne
est différente de nous,
pour quand même se sentir en paix.
Mieux encore :
comment faire pour participer
à ce qu’elle aussi se sente en paix,
malgré notre différence ?
Et, ainsi, par effet de rayonnement,
participer à un monde
qui soit quelque part plus accueillant,
plus sécure, en somme.
Pour vous expliquer cela,
je vais revenir sur ces fameuses
trente premières années de ma vie.
Comme je vous disais,
j’étais beaucoup dans la tête à
me demander ce qui était bien ou mal.
C’était totalement inconscient,
c’était mon éducation.
Peut-être que vous remarquerez
que, chez vous,
vous avez reçu à peu près
le même type d’éducation.
Je vous invite à vérifier.
Quoi qu’il en soit, chez moi, c’était ça.
Je vérifiais chez moi, chez l’autre :
« Est-ce que c’est bien, mal ? »
J’étais dans le jugement perpétuel.
Et, en réalité, j’en souffrais énormément.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que nous n’avons pas tous
la même conception du bien et du mal.
On n’a pas les mêmes cadres de référence,
on n’a pas les mêmes préférences.
Ça explique
qu’on n’ait pas les mêmes avis,
que l’on fasse des choix
parfois qui s’opposent.
Que ce soit dans tous
les vecteurs de la vie :
dans la famille,
avec les amis, au travail,
dans la vie amoureuse
et dans la société.
Regardez avec la crise du COVID :
certains considèrent
qu’il devrait être obligatoire
de porter le masque
et de se faire vacciner.
Tout simplement pour
pouvoir enrayer la pandémie
et prendre soin de la santé du peuple.
Là, où d’autres considèrent le contraire :
ça ne devrait pas être obligatoire
de porter le masque
et de se faire vacciner.
Et ce dans le but de respecter
la liberté de tous, la singularité,
et également l’intégrité
physique de chacun.
Un autre exemple :
certains considèrent que
le port du voile devrait être interdit,
et ce pour manifester
l’égalité entre les citoyens.
D’autres considèrent que
non, au contraire,
ils veulent pouvoir porter leur voile,
parce que,
dans leurs convictions religieuses,
c’est vraiment œuvrer pour le bien.
Un autre exemple, un dernier.
Il y a ceux qui considèrent
que la cuvette des toilettes
devrait rester levée.
Là, où d’autres pensent
qu’elle devrait rester baissée.
Bon, on est d’accord,
sur tout plein de domaines,
on va vivre des divergences,
et parfois des convergences, d’ailleurs.
Mais quoi qu’il en soit,
on ne peut pas s’entendre sur tout.
Si je reviens à mon histoire,
le problème, c’est que je le vivais mal.
Parce qu’en fait, j’avais l’impression
de vivre des jeux de pouvoir
dans toutes mes relations,
quasiment toutes, en tout cas.
Je n’étais pas heureuse, mais vraiment.
Je pourrais appeler ça un « burn-out
relationnel », on va inventer le mot.
Mais j’étais vraiment éreintée, fatiguée,
et j’en suis arrivée
jusqu’à la dépression,
tellement ça m’insupportait.
J’avais l’impression qu’il y avait
toujours des perdants dans l’histoire.
Alors que moi, au plus profond,
je n’avais qu’une envie : qu’on vive
du gagnant-gagnant entre nous.
J’avais envie que chacun
puisse vivre sa pleine singularité,
tout en se sentant en paix, être aimé,
bien qu’on soit différent.
J’avais un peu l’impression
d’être seule à penser ça.
Donc, en pleine dépression,
je vais à une conférence,
une éternelle conférence.
À un moment donné, sur le côté,
je vois un prospectus qui traîne,
informant d’une formation
sur la communication non-violente.
« Qu’est-ce que c’est que ce truc ? »
Et le peu de mots que je vois,
« Waouh ! Ça me parle, ça. »
Je rentre vite fait chez moi,
je regarde sur Internet.
Et tous les mots, toutes les indications
me disent que ça ressemble
aux valeurs que je viens de vous évoquer.
Je décide de m’inscrire,
et je vivais exactement enfin ces valeurs.
Mais le plus formidable dans tout ça,
c’est que ce n’était pas seulement
des idées un peu bisounours,
c’était quelque chose de pratico-pratique,
que je pouvais vraiment
mettre en application dans ma vie,
et qui fonctionnait.
Alors, je me suis formée, j’ai adoré.
Seulement la petite mauvaise
nouvelle là-dedans,
c’est qu’il a fallu que je change.
Eh oui !
Il a fallu que je modifie
ma façon de voir les choses,
et plus particulièrement,
ma façon de voir l’autre.
Eh oui !
Que j’arrête d’analyser
la fameuse posture du juge.
Que j’arrête de juger
l’autre, et moi d’ailleurs,
et les situations.
Et que je considère qu’il y’avait
peut-être une autre façon de procéder,
celle que nous invite à avoir
la communication non-violente,
qui consiste à être dans une perception
plus sensorielle, plus émotionnelle,
quelque chose plus à l’écoute du corps.
En fait, c’est un formidable indicateur
de ce que l’on vit,
de notre humanité, en somme.
C’est ce que nous ressentons
nous tous, les êtres humains.
Alors, voilà ce que je vous propose :
eh bien, c’est de mettre de côté -
d’essayer du moins -
de mettre de côté cette posture
du juge qui analyse
au service d’une autre posture,
en vous imaginant ce petit fil,
que l’on peut appeler
le fil de l’humanité.
Imaginez-vous que ce fil nous relie,
les êtres humains,
entre nous.
Dans cette similarité que nous avons
à simplement ressentir des émotions,
et avoir tous des besoins universels.
Je vous expliquerai un peu plus tard
ce qu’on va faire avec ce fil.
Mais avant ça,
j’avais envie de vous partager un moment
qui m’a vraiment bouleversée.
Comme je vous ai dit, j’étais à fond,
je voulais apprendre la CNV,
la communication non-violente,
et je n’arrêtais pas,
alors je lisais aussi beaucoup.
Je lisais un ouvrage
de Marshall Rosenberg,
le fondateur de la communication
non-violente, qui s’appelle :
« Les mots sont des fenêtres
(ou ce sont des murs) »
Je vous le recommande
chaleureusement au passage.
Alors dedans,
il parle d’une de ses anecdotes,
parce qu’il a fait beaucoup
d’interventions à l’international.
Il était à Bethléem,
dans un camp de réfugiés,
où il y avait 170 personnes.
Et, puis, à un moment donné,
il y a une rumeur -
donc moi je lis le bouquin -
et il raconte qu’il y a une rumeur
qui court dans l’assemblée,
et là un homme s’écrie :
« Vous êtes un tueur d’enfants ! »
Je ne vous raconte pas,
quand je lis ça, je me dis :
« Comment il va réagir? »
J’étais au taquet.
Et là, Marshall, qu’est-ce qu’il a fait ?
Il a répondu,
parce que, en fait,
il était au courant que tout le monde
en voulait aux États-Unis
de vendre des armes à Israël.
Alors il a répondu à cet homme :
« Est-ce que vous êtes en colère
parce que vous aimeriez que mon pays
fasse un autre usage de ses ressources ?
Est-ce que vous aimeriez que mon pays
vous aide dans vos conditions de vie ?
- Exactement ! »
Vous, vos enfants,
ils ont des écoles,
ils ont des terrains de jeux,
parce que le mien, d’enfant,
là où il joue,
c’est dans les égouts. »
Et cet homme a continué à parler
de sa souffrance pendant vingt minutes.
Marshall s’est contenté
d’écouter cet homme.
Non pas en écoutant son attaque,
non pas en écoutant ses mots
où il le traitait d’assassin,
mais en recevant chacune de ses paroles.
En allant repérer les sentiments
et les besoins implicites,
derrière chacune de ses déclarations.
En n’entendant pas cela comme des attaques
mais comme le don d’un semblable,
qui partage ses rancœurs,
qui partage sa vulnérabilité.
Et après cela, cet homme,
il avait vécu suffisamment d’écoute,
de compréhension, de respect
pour être à même d’écouter
ce pourquoi Marshall venait,
c’est-à-dire partager les bienfaits
de la communication non-violente.
Alors, quand j’ai lu ça dans ce bouquin,
waouh !,
j’étais juste bluffée !
Je me suis dit : « Mais... »
Ça m’a tellement inspirée.
Je me dis : « Moi, je veux être comme lui.
J’ai envie d’offrir cette paix aux autres,
de pouvoir participer
à ce monde plus en paix. »
Donc j’étais complètement emballée
et c’est la raison pour laquelle
je me suis beaucoup formée
et que j’ai fait le choix
d’être formatrice.
Et aujourd’hui, je suis vraiment,
tellement heureuse,
de réaliser que
mes relations n’ont plus rien à voir.
Je vis cette qualité
qui est beaucoup plus profonde,
beaucoup plus dans la connexion.
Je vais vous raconter une anecdote,
c’était l’année dernière exactement.
J’animais un module 1
de communication non-violente,
et l’une des stagiaires était venue,
notamment parce que ses collègues
de boulot lui avaient dit :
« Il faudrait que tu fasses
un stage de CNV. »
Et assez rapidement,
quand elle est arrivée,
j’ai compris pourquoi ils disaient ça.
En fait,
pendant ces deux jours de formation,
régulièrement, elle m’interrompait,
pour partager son avis, mais surtout,
pour juger la façon dont j’animais,
et également le contenu.
Je me souviens, elle m’a dit :
« Mais qu’est-ce que tu es lente ! »
À un autre moment : « C’est mou ! »
À un autre moment,
elle a commencé à dire :
« Oui, mais enfin, tout ça,
c’est de la théorie,
en réalité, ce n’est pas réalisable. »
À un autre moment,
elle a dit tout simplement
qu’elle ne voulait pas
participer à l’exercice.
Voilà, je vous passe les détails,
c’était assez intense.
Alors, c’est très, très rare que ça arrive
et, en même temps,
c’était ce qui était vivant pour elle.
Alors, voilà, j’ai accueilli
chacune de ses interactions,
en allant repérer ces fameux sentiments,
ces fameux besoins
qu’elle nous partageait,
jusqu’à ce qu’elle vive suffisamment
de compréhension, d’empathie,
pour qu’à son tour,
elle soit prête aussi
à écouter ce qui pouvait se jouer
pour moi également.
Et alors, peu à peu -
à chaque fois on a fait ça -
peu à peu, on trouvait des solutions,
qui lui aillent à elle,
qui m’aillent à moi,
qui aillent à tout le groupe.
Je ne vous cache pas que,
quand le module 2 est arrivé
quelques mois après,
je me suis dit :
« Pas sûr qu’elle se réinscrive. »
J’ai été hyper surprise
de voir son nom sur la liste.
Elle arrive,
elle était métamorphosée.
Le visage hyper paisible.
Pendant toute la formation,
une attitude détendue.
Rien à voir, personne n'en revenait.
Et pendant la formation,
elle vient me voir :
« Élodie, il faut que je te dise un truc.
Je voudrais te remercier
pour la formation module 1,
et surtout de partager quelque
chose qui s’est passé pour moi.
En fait, deux jours après la formation,
je n’ai pas compris ce qui s’est passé.
Tout d’un coup, je me suis sentie en paix.
J’ai eu l’impression que quelque chose
avait complètement lâché. »
Waouh, quand elle m’a dit ça,
j’ai compris pourquoi
je la voyais métamorphosée.
Et ça m’a fait tellement chaud au cœur,
rien que de vous le repartager là,
c’est à nouveau très présent,
parce que je me rends compte
à quel point si je fais ça,
et c’est pour ce plaisir
que je vis, bien sûr,
de me relier à chaque être,
quel qu’il soit.
Mais c’est aussi pour voir
cette joie, cette paix,
œuvrer chez l’autre
cette transformation qui opère.
Alors, voilà !
Si ça vous donne envie
de vivre des choses
un petit peu similaires,
je vous propose
de vivre une petite expérience.
L’expérience est la suivante :
je vous parlais
de ce fameux fil tout à l’heure.
Le fil de l’humanité.
La prochaine fois que vous rencontrez
quelqu’un qui se comporte
diamétralement opposé
à ce que vous aimeriez,
essayez de vous imaginer
ce fil de l’humanité qui vous relie.
Vous l’imaginez, ok ?
Et je vous invite à vous poser
la question suivante pour vous y aider :
« Quel est son besoin ? »
Quand elle se comporte comme cela,
quand elle parle ainsi,
à votre avis, c’est pour nourrir
quel besoin ?
Est-ce que c’est un besoin d’amour ?
Un besoin de sécurité ?
De partage ?
De légèreté ?
Tenez, quand je vois une mère
dans la rue qui crie sur son enfant,
moi, je ne le cautionne pas,
je suis mal à l’aise avec ça.
Parce que j’ai envie
qu’il y ait de la bienveillance.
J’ai envie qu’il y ait
du soin qui soit apporté,
du respect,
de l’intégrité psychologique, de l’amour.
Donc je ne renie absolument pas
le tragique de la situation.
Et, en même temps,
je peux vraiment me relier à cette mère,
par ce fil d’humanité
en me posant la question :
« Quel est son besoin ? »
Je peux m’imaginer que peut-être
qu’elle se sent terriblement démunie
parce qu’elle aimerait
être entendue par son enfant,
et qu’elle a un besoin d’écoute.
Ou peut-être qu’elle est tellement
investie par son rôle de mère
qui veut transmettre
quelque chose à son enfant,
parce qu’elle aimerait être
rassurée qu’il va s’en sortir dans la vie.
Ou qu’elle nourrit
un besoin de transmission,
un besoin de sécurité aussi pour elle.
Alors, vous voyez ?
Je peux me relier
à cet être humain,
malgré nos choix différents.
Alors, voilà ce que je vous propose :
c’est de vivre cette expérience
la prochaine fois,
ou pourquoi pas plusieurs fois ?
De vous imaginer la prochaine fois
que vous voyez quelqu’un
qui se comporte différemment de vous,
dont vous n’aimez pas l’attitude -
Allez, essayez !
Essayez de mettre de côté ce juge
qui analyse, qui est en train
de juger l’autre, essayez !
Visualisez ce fil,
et posez-vous la question :
« Quel peut bien être son besoin ? »
Et si à force de vivre cette expérience,
vous sentez que, peu à peu,
votre cœur s’ouvre,
vous vous sentez plus en paix,
alors bienvenue
dans la communication non-violente.
Merci infiniment pour votre écoute.
(Applaudissements)